laughter Muller's remarks yesterday it
wasn't simply the Democratic
presidential field that lost its mine
Hollywood obviously did - led by actor
Robert De Niro he started a new public
service announcement that claims the
president obstructed justice
watch this you may have seen me on
Saturday Night Live as a certain federal
prosecutor that was acting but now we're
going to hear from some real federal
prosecutors I have so much admiration
for their intelligence and dedication to
their work recently over a thousand
former federal prosecutors who served
under both Republican and Democratic
presidents have united to sign a
statement to help Americans understand
what's actually in the muddled report
their conclusion should trouble us all
in the words of the Muller report no
person is above the law no person is
above the law but certain rich
well-known people would like an outsized
role in guiding what America does next
Robert De Niro would fit into that small
category this is part of a long term
obsession denier has with Donald Trump
here's another example it's just beyond
surreal what this guy is done
you called him a mutt he's a month you
still believe he's every word I said
then I just mean today this idiot is the
president the guy is a fool come on how
dare you say the things he does of
course I want to punch him in the face
[Applause]
it's a man who yells at his driver
speaking on behalf of all of us in rich
person well mark Stein is not throwing
columnist one of our favorite guests
joins us tonight so what do you I mean I
don't understand and I know we've talked
about this before but why is it if
you're Robert De Niro or any of these
people they're very pinnacle of American
society that you're monomaniacal about
Trump why the obsession well I I think
it gets back to the the famous line back
at when Nixon won
the New Yorkers film critic wrote that
she didn't know anyone who voted for
Nixon yes in this case it's even worse
that they don't know anyone who they
will loathe Trump they don't know anyone
who voted for Trump and therefore
because they see themselves as exemplars
of ordinary everyday Americans Trump
cannot have won which is why this whole
Russian collusion thing got going and
it's interesting to me for example that
there's that we're doing real damage to
important aspects of our society in
letting Robert De Niro make the running
on this Robert De Niro introduces a
group of about 12 prosecutors on that
video representing a thousand Democrats
and Republicans who who say that Trump
is guilty of obstruction of justice
now two things if you thought Trump was
really guilty of obstruction of justice
and you wanted to do impartial justice
why would you stick a man whose most
famous for saying F Trump at the Tony
Awards on the front of that video
whatever that is that's that's not even
the potentially impartial justice and
secondly just to go back to what you and
Shawn we're talking about with this new
standard whereby you have to be
proclaimed innocent by the state it's
not enough just to be not guilty you
have to be proclaimed innocent we have
something weirder going on with these
thousand prosecutors we have a jury of
prosecutors that is complete Alice in
Wonderland if ocation of the of the
balance of common law law for a thousand
years it's a complete nonsense Tucker
but doesn't it make it easier I mean you
don't really have to worry about the
outcome when you have the prosecutors
acting is the jury you know the verdict
is gonna be guilty right so isn't that
just a it was a sort of streamlined
process yeah I know especially we daddy
what an stinking corrupt federal justice
to pray see what I've said on your show
before you know this is why it's
important to know the date at which at
which Robert Molyneux there is no
collusion
that's all conspiracy because everything
after that it just goes to the American
method of the processes the the
punishment and and for Trump to be
indicted for obstruction of justice for
something he said six months after
Robert Muller knew there was no
collusion or conspiracy would be a
perversion even by the mountain of
perversions that federal justice has
heaped on traditional common law
protections I would not want to be
charged with a crime right now I never
thought I'd say that
I know rate no I'd be worried no I'll
Drive you across the border to Canada
get under the tarp in my pickup Tucker
it's a free Dale because you can't win
with these guys it feels that way
marks time great to see you tonight
thank you thanks a lot chugga